right what I want to talk about today is
new things touch do items touch do
molecules touch and I bring my hands
together are they actually touching or
are they repelling those aren't quite a
lot on the internet and in the physics
forums and the chemistry forums and in
reddit and a range of other fora about
this question so it's pretty close to my
heart because what arrived in my inbox
yesterday my mailbox was this so this is
my field of research non-contact atomic
force microscopy the thing that puzzles
me is if things never really contact
each other why do we draw distinctions
between non-contact and contact atomic
force microscopy what is that
distinction so there is a such thing as
contact atomic force Marcos there is
indeed this contact mode and there's
non-contact mode and I tell the
first-year students about this a lot and
they actually a number of them have
referred to this discussion on the
internet same one actually will you know
but particularly in the first couple of
weeks when they come in this you are
aware you're holding a cup of tea sorry
just let me take one more slug of it now
put it over here stupid it's even closer
to my heart because at the moment I've
been working on this paper all over the
last couple of weeks where we do what we
called and others before us have called
point-contact probe microscopy notice
the word contact we go back to 1986 the
inventors of the scanning tunneling
microscope in the atomic force
microscope so these are two tools that
allow us to see in not only individual
atoms but the state of the artist to see
individual bonds and I've waffle at
length about these in previous videos
just because you use the word doesn't
automatically mean it's happening the
important thing is we can have a very
rigid definition of what contact means
and the problem is with the discussions
some of the discussions on the internet
the argument seems to be here's one atom
let's call it a molecule here's one
molecule here's another molecule the
problem with a lot of the discussions is
that well you bring these molecules
together you bring them together and
then they start to repel that's wrong
that's that's that's fundamentally wrong
that's not what happens you bring two
molecules together even if they don't
form a chemical bond
they attract something called the Vander
Waals force and they where it originates
from is that you've got electrons over
here you've got electrons over here Quan
mechanics tells us that we don't pin
those electrons down to this particular
location so the fluctuating here and the
fluctuating here that means that on very
small fractions of time you're getting
dipoles you're getting a charge a slight
charge imbalance and that slight charge
and balance over here not slight charge
imbalance over here gives rise to an
attractive force and that's really
important belong before you get to the
repulsive side you have an attractive
force where we can define contact very
easily is at the point where that
attractive force is balanced by the
repulsive force and those discussions on
the inter a quite correct them is a
repulsive force and it's ultimately due
to something called the Pauli exclusion
principle which basically well let's not
go into the whole details of the Pauli
exclusion principle lots of videos and
sixty symbols about that we have a very
well-defined position at which the net
force the balance of the repulsive and
the attractive contributions is zero and
that actually defines the bond length or
defines the intermolecular separation if
we don't have a chemical bond but we do
not need a sharing of electrons we do
not need an exchange of an electrons
this van der Waals force which is
everywhere around us the typical example
is how does the Gecko stick everywhere
and it's due to the found ultimately due
to this van der Waals force so let me
point out two things get those balls
where you have dip let me point out two
things you've just done there first of
all you've made a big point of this is
the definition of context so you're
saying this is just a definition no but
it's it's what we need to know is what
do we do in science all the time we try
to have rigid definitions we try to have
rigid criteria you know when we think
about simple laws like f is equal to em
here okay etc I'm willing to accept that
I'm even willing to accept that's a
scientific definition of contact even
when you were doing that analogy for me
you kept the balls apart you didn't make
the balls touch each other but the
important thing yeah but then the issue
here is what we mean by contact ok so
right so what is science or is this
always talking about words
definitions I guess you know those two
things are always in turn trinsic li
entangled you know definitions and what
we mean and what analogies we use and
what models we use how accurate are they
my concern is this idea of which is
demonstrably wrong
domani because we do this measurement in
the lab on a daily basis we take one
molecule up here we bring it to another
and we measure that force directly and
we can see where that force turns around
well that force goes to zero due to this
balance of the attractive importance
once you reach this point that you tell
me is contact yep can they move any
closer if they move closer they get a
repulsive force in the opposite
direction that's the key thing if they
move closer they start to experience a
repulsive force and if they never came
into contact we can measure this
directly hang on we can measure this
directly in the experiment we can bring
this one molecule in and we can crush
this one how do you get atomic positions
which are changing if you're crushing
one molecule the simple fact that you
say once you reach the contact point if
we move them even closer they start
repelling the simple fact that they can
even be moved close how do we desist ooh
me that they were in cannot but how do
we define contact in this case on the
macroscopic world right how do we bring
this in we bring it there right so I can
push down on it but if at the point of
contact right if we try to I really need
a feel I don't think anyone is arguing
about the definition of contacting the
macroscopic level every right okay well
that's fine take okay right so on the
microscopic level the thing that I find
concerning is the idea that it's only
electron repulsion attraction is not
mentioned even when you've got what are
called physical interactions so not
chemical interactions this type of
interaction put my hand as right at the
atomic and the molecular level there is
an attractive force there before that
repulsive force comes in and it's the
balance of those two forces exactly so
you know you've got something falling
under gravity right okay so we've got a
reaction force from the floor you know
how do you define contact in this case
it's we're basically just scaling down
that type of idea down to the atomic
level because why else would we have
another
finition let me tell you how how I feel
about what you've just said at the very
start you use the analogy of clapping
hands and you said some people say these
two hands have not come into contact you
said that's not true let me tell you why
you then showed me this stuff about van
der Waals force you showed me this this
magic point where the two forces reach
in equilibrium and do you know what I
took from that my hands don't touch when
I clap but they get to this point where
these four what okay there and they
never quite right well let's not was the
repulsive well then let's go this way
well then let's define what you mean by
touching do you mean that the nuclear
cores come together
you mean that the nuclear code because
if so that's you know there is really no
point in discussion because if CC energy
scales are completely out of reach we're
not going to have if we could have nukes
jeez if we could have nuclear fusion by
doing that wonderful it's about a
question of how do you define our
contact point and my point is that that
point in science is pretty well defined
well what are the fundamental quantities
and physics energy mass force etc and so
if we're talking about four so let's
make a definition on the balance of
forces so you're very much more natural
than the definition of contact the point
where these two forces balance out and
we can't move the atom closer yeah no no
I didn't say we can't move the atom
closer okay well then if we can move the
atom closer I argue they're not in
contact because that we could move them
closer right so let's go back to this
let's go back to this are they in
contact hang on
are you talking about them as footballs
where Adam Earth's footballs are they in
contact yes if I do that my squeeze down
on that one
right so that's exactly what's happening
when you push these in you get a
repulsive force but the important thing
is where do you have to it's not like we
have a switch on it's not like the force
to switch on and switch off
instantaneously over you're very very
small ranges they they very smoothly
I must admit that's one definition you
can have other definitions of the
contact point yeah right so if it's a
chemical bond for example you could say
right at the point at which the overlap
of the electron density is such-and-such
will define matter so the important
thing is that the physics is such we can
dress it up in whatever mathematical
language you like but the physics is
such
that at the atomic level we have contact
because otherwise why would I why would
we call these techniques non-contact in
context but here's what I think here's a
scientific definition of what I think a
normal person would think of as contact
between two particles I think and what
all these normals all these analogies
are trying to get at I think true
contact between two particles say two
electrons is the point at which the
space occupied by the electron could
have no Planck lengths between it and
the space occupied by another electron
but at a point where you could no longer
fit like the point of the electron has
zero Planck lengths between the electron
to the fundamental in quantum mechanics
you can never have that but that's
that's an extreme definition where would
you use that definition that's like
saying you're going to define contact as
when I overlap this football with the
other one and they occupy the same space
that's exactly what you saying when you
touched them they got to a point where I
could no longer put a piece of paper
between them and so they're in contact
for like on the map but you're arguing
that if two two electrons occupy the
same space it's the same space
there's just no longer the probe yeah
but the problem is you know from you've
done these videos of the years we cannot
define an electron like a particle like
that so there that's why things can't
conjugate so therefore the analogy my
point again is the analogy breaks down
and you've got to come up you've got to
use a scientific definition that
everybody can agree with I agree it has
clear delineation points which is very
helpful for a definition and if that's
the definition you want that's fine but
I think your definition of contact your
scientific definition of contact the
point where for sex and force where I
come into balance isn't what the normal
but the problem is you can't extend what
the normal person thinks about touching
down to the quantum level so you have to
come up with and under the definition
your analogy breaks down analogy
entirely breaks down yet because you
cannot extend it down to the quantum
level so when people make these videos
or have these discussions that upset you
where they say things don't contact what
I think they're due
is these people have realized the wonder
of what's going on at this microscopic
but they have this x-ray
let me think oh sorry so they realize
the wonder of what's happening at this
nano level and a really good way to
convey the wonder of that is to say to
you know what these things aren't even
touch I agree and I agree but you have
to be careful to the extent to which you
overplay that new hybrid this is the
important thing and it's that it's true
not just in terms of public engagement
in terms of YouTube videos and education
via via online channels etc it's true
also in terms of the science we do it's
very easy for us to over hyper results
and give them our connection to the real
world that might not be justified you've
got to be very careful when you put
analogies across to explain what the
deficiencies might be in those analogous